how are you guys doing i want that
t-shirt
you can get it i can help you make i can
make that happen i love that that's such
a good one yeah you can't go wrong with
rodney
not even a little um i really want to
start with uh thank you for making me
laugh i really appreciate it uh and you
know it's hard to make comedies and i
just want to say thank you
um
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you guys today while watching the
movie i did learn and i've heard that
sometimes people are doing press like
this and perhaps they don't like each
other but you know brave face you know
promote the movie you demonstrate it in
the film so i'm curious um who hates who
here
well i hate karen maria hates iris iris
hates me yeah and and i like everyone
i can't believe this we all love each
other yeah
do you yes yeah actually yeah
everybody's going really well right yeah
yeah everybody got along great maybe
because we were playing actors who hated
each other it's like everything was
channeled out there and then we could
just have a nice
environment i'm thinking but i'm okay i
will believe you something else in this
movie and i've seen watching interviews
sometimes actors get asked to solve like
real world problems during a junket
which is to me effing crazy so i am
curious what is like some of the
strangest stuff you've been asked by a
journalist they're like you wish you
could say are you effin kidding me but
you still have to put on a brave face
that's a great question
i always just change it up i can i
somebody will ask me some ridiculous
question that i shouldn't be answering
and i just give an answer about
something completely
off like different from what they're
asking me so i'll i'll answer something
about my children
or
i don't listen i don't like answer their
question at all somebody asked me about
council culture once which is a valid
question but i find myself being like i
don't know how to navigate this like
yeah am i going to end up being
counseled by the end of my answer
yes that's totally valid by the way yeah
you guys
i don't this is my first time that's her
first time doing is this is it the first
time yeah i'm like really
[ __ ] terrified they're so good at it
i believe that's just some training yeah
i i have some actor friends and they
have definitely done what's called the
media training yes i had to do that
which i've been anticipating really
really bad quite like scary questions
and it's been pretty good so far i
haven't freaked out don't ruin it for
her i know i promise i don't i don't
have anything i have no uh fastballs
coming i promise
um anything that you have been i don't
think so but that's my first like in
person press junket as well this is i
did not know and i'm just gonna say i'm
glad i'm here so i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
something i promise is not hard-hitting
this movie has a surprising amount of
dancing in it and uh i really enjoyed
that aspect of it and i'm just curious
for you guys is it scarier to dance on
camera or to have like a four-page
dialogue scene i think dancing was
scarier
yeah because we're not dancers but they
treated us like we were yeah they're
really great they yeah they were like
really hard on us especially iris
and um and they
like it was brutal wasn't it oh yeah we
did more rehearsals for the dancing than
we did for any acting um it was like
they needed to make us become dancers
yeah and uh people were injured like
pedro
had to roll his back in between
rehearsing
the dance routine
yeah
it was hard yeah but it was fun
and we were in shape and like it was a
fun bonding experience yeah all of the
rehearsals yeah i also it looks really
good but this year is interesting
because peacemaker had their opening
credits is a dance number
it's phenomenal you guys had some great
dancing the euphoria finale had some
dance like it's it's just been
interesting and i very much have enjoyed
it
maybe we're coming out with the pandemic
and we just need to get the glasses
yes um
i like learning about the behind the
scenes of like the making of a movie so
for each of you what is something that
might surprise soon to be fans of the
movie to like learn about the making of
the movie and if it's nothing surprising
you could just share like a cool day on
set
i think um i thought it was cool that
everyone um
hung out in between scenes shooting
scenes they stayed in a green room
and like talked to each other instead of
going off to their trailers
and being alone they all stayed together
i think everyone was so excited to be
around other people and so and excited
to talk to other people because we've
been isolating for so long and um i
thought that was that was pretty cool
like everyone is actually friends
yeah do you guys want to add anything
else i i was just excited to like
see people as well i was very
like i would just like sit next to maria
and be like so who's your first
boyfriend what would you do
did you have a good day
like i guess i could have a cocktail
because it's legal and then just sit on
the grass it's like the things that i i
was just excited to literally do
anything because
isolation but obviously
we're in a bad situation we just we're
still crazy it was crazy because we were
shooting the bubble in england when uk
had the biggest lockdown yeah and they
weren't allowed to even go for a walk
with more than one person yeah and yeah
this is strict really strange that was
the best place to be yeah especially in
new york yeah i didn't even think about
that that that's when you were filming
it yeah that so and that's so
interesting and also there's scenes in
the movie where everyone's wearing masks
and all that stuff it's
i'm sure the covet safety officer that
day was like this is how it needs to be
every day yeah you know yeah yeah it was
just weird because it was like on and
off camera so everything was like
blurring and i was like what is even
real anymore yeah
um i am curious if netflix actually and
it's possible if they really make a
cliff beast's movie after making this
film will you each get residuals do you
get residuals if it's streaming no
that's the big argument right now yeah
you don't
we should
that's a whole nother that's a whole
nother i wasn't going to open that door
but that's a whole nother
numbers of streams well i've had
conversations with with people who make
movies who actually appreciate the
netflix model because they don't have to
go chasing for residuals yeah because
they know what they're going to make and
they don't have to fight people that's a
good point and so there's two sides to
it but but i do think that if a movie's
a huge hit you should be compensated
yeah
yeah i don't really understand no i'm
sure netflix is very happy with me right
now they are over the moon right now
you know what i mean um so for each of
you though um uh judd has known he's
known obviously for making sometimes
longer movies movies that could approach
you know a longer run time i'm curious
did you end up with a lot of deleted
scenes were you like for example talking
to judd being like how are you not using
this scene no
i think the conversation is always um
maybe you can lose that scene yeah maybe
you can lose this other scene yeah i
think i think it's more like we would
talk about how there's like if this
movie in full could be 16 hours
and five different movies like
everything that was happening was like i
think this is what could happen and then
we would do it but it like i mean most
of the stuff didn't see the light yeah
there was a whole other dance number
that didn't see the light of day oh yeah
there's some yeah because it's a largely
improvised movie there's just like so
many scenes so they would yeah they
would have like the huge dinner table
and then every single person had their
own
like improvised speech uh speech yeah
and they're just different versions were
caught up
see this is the kind of thing that
should be released like the list could
be released on tick tock like the dance
number is like an extra for the movie
because we all it was very
it was it was strange but it was really
good wait which one yeah
[Applause]
yeah it's almost i mean you might know
someone who could possibly get this
released i'm just throwing that up you
know you might know
just hypothetically um so was that like
the biggest thing that didn't make the
final cut
um i don't i i i don't remember
everything it was a big one didn't you
everybody worked really hard that was
the that was the i thought it was the
funniest one
i need to see this yeah i really enjoyed
the i really enjoyed the dance numbers i
got to stop already i'm just going to
say for real thank you for making me
laugh and um just you know good luck
with the rest of the speed dating
you